[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de Ucrania
dimitroculeva Muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros es un placer el presidente
zelensky dice repite que cree que
Ucrania puede ganar la guerra en 2023
hemos oído al jefe de Estado Mayor del
ejército de Estados Unidos expresar
dudas al respecto el presidente francés
el canciller Alemán dicen que será una
guerra larga sinceramente cree que En
definitiva pueden ganar esta guerra este
año
si no creemos que podemos ganar esta
guerra Entonces por qué estamos luchando
queremos que esta guerra termine más que
cualquiera en el mundo por supuesto que
ese es Nuestro objetivo
y estamos tratando de movilizar todos
los recursos para eso
el presidente Putin ha dicho que quiere
seguir
parece que su estrategia es una guerra
de desgaste
esperando dejar a Ucrania sin
resistencia más en municiones
y hay algunos sectores en occidente
preocupados porque la corriente en el
campo de batalla este cambiando en
contra de Ucrania en este momento creo
que esos sectores deberían ocuparse de
sí mismos
la corriente no está cambiando porque
Ucrania está luchando por la causa
correcta en esencia Ucrania está
luchando contra el derecho del más
fuerte a atacar al más débil
contra el derecho del más fuerte
imponerle su voluntad al vecino al que
considera más débil
defendemos la ley internacional
defendemos la carta de las Naciones
Unidas y por lo tanto la verdad está de
nuestro lado
Entonces todos los que creen en la
verdad y en la necesidad de respetar la
soberanía y la integridad territorial de
los países deberían estar de nuestro
lado lo que ustedes necesitan es por
supuesto sanciones dinero pero Quizás lo
más importante sea armas hubo un acuerdo
para enviar tanques a Ucrania Pero qué
está pasando entre el acuerdo y la
realidad
Cuál es la situación de este asunto
fundamental para Ucrania
necesitamos armas sanciones dinero y
solidaridad
y entre esos cuatro elementos cada país
del mundo puede escoger Cuál es el mejor
para sí mismo por ejemplo si un país del
sur global no quiere enviar armas puede
expresar solidaridad política con
Ucrania y con los principios que
defienden votando a favor de la
resolución consecutivas en la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas
otros pueden enviar armas otros pueden
dar dinero otros pueden imponer
sanciones hay muchas maneras de apoyar a
Ucrania en cuanto a la coalición de
tanques sí existe
ya se están llevando a cabo algunos
entrenamientos con tanques
algunos países están resolviendo asuntos
con las piezas de repuesto para los
tanques que quieren desplegar en Ucrania
Entonces no dudo de que este proceso
está en marcha y solo es cuestión de
tiempo para que lo esta semana tres
meses semanas semanas y los aviones de
combate sobre esto todavía no ha habido
un acuerdo
Usted cree que sería bueno anticiparse
Este es un proyecto más largo plazo pero
no demasiado largo
los aviones no deberían considerarse de
manera aislada Por eso no hablamos de
aviones
sino de plataformas los aviones también
son importantes como parte del sistema
de defensa aéreo
para batir misiles rusos que atacan
nuestra infraestructura energética clave
y mata a civiles
la estrategia en cuanto a los aviones es
diferente en comparación con otras armas
en el caso de las armas anteriores
normalmente funciona de la siguiente
manera primero se anunció la decisión de
entregar armas y después se organizaron
entrenamientos para que los soldados
ucranianos aprendieran a usar esas armas
ahora nosotros proponemos invertirlo y
empezar primero los entrenamientos para
los pilotos ucranianos mientras se toma
la decisión final sobre los aviones Pero
esto significa que cree que los f-16 o
los mig eventualmente se enviarán a
Ucrania a pesar de la oposición en
Washington y en otros lugares no veo
posición en ni en otros lugares creo que
más bien deberíamos hablar de un proceso
de toma de decisión
es cierto que todavía no se han tomado
decisiones pero no tengo dudas de qué
estas decisiones se tomarán mire desde
febrero del año pasado en Ucrania
sabíamos que debíamos recibir siete
tipos de armas para ser capaces de
detener a Rusia y sacar la de Ucrania
en 12 meses hemos recibido seis de siete
las llamamos las siete grandes y seis de
las siete categorías ya están completas
y cada arma cada categoría empezó con un
No que al final se volvió Entonces no
tengo dudas de que el mismo patrón
aplicará para los aviones usted ha dicho
que mientras Vladimir Putin está en el
kremlin
Ucrania está en problemas esto
obviamente implica que debería haber un
cambio de régimen en Moscú
para que pueda haber paz en Ucrania
no solo Ucrania está en problemas
fíjense en los balcanes fíjense en
África Central donde Los mercenarios
Wagner con el apoyo del gobierno ruso
están causando problemas y generando
presión en los vecinos estables
fíjense
en todas partes del mundo y verá que la
estrategia del presidente Putin es la
destrucción
y también se enfoca en menoscabar la
estabilidad en distintas partes del
mundo
porque la única posibilidad de que Putin
gane por lo menos algo
es generando inestabilidad
Rusia y más específicamente el
presidente Putin
no es solo un problema para Ucrania
es un problema mundial También es un
problema para el sur global
es un problema para el norte global a
nadie le interesa tener un miembro
permanente el consejo de seguridad de
las Naciones Unidas y del poder nuclear
metiéndose con el mundo y tratando de
desestabilizar la situación en todas
partes entonces mientras él esté ahí
habrá problemas el mundo debería
deshacerse de él eso es lo que usted
propone Porque algunos líderes en
occidente Emanuel Mako olafles dicen no
No deberíamos acabar con Rusia no hay
que humillarlo hay que seguir hablando
con él Usted cree que esto está mal
no he oído llamados para no humillar a
Putin en varios meses
esa narrativa existió antes de que
empezara la invasión a gran escala en
Ucrania
y es una narrativa fallida solo las
personas de Rusia
deberían decidir quién liderará a Rusia
la cuestión es cómo hacer que las
personas de Rusia entiendan que Putin es
también su problema y que su vida será
mucho mejor sin él qué pasa con china
china está diciendo que quiere mediar
ofrecer un plan de paz también hemos
escuchado que Estados Unidos le dice una
advertencia a China sobre el envío de
ayuda letal a Rusia Cuál es su opinión
en esas dos cuestiones relacionadas con
china
por supuesto todo el mundo ve a China
como un poder global
y esperamos ver esas propuestas de paz
que el señor wangie el jefe diplomático
chino usted se reunió con él hace poco
sí lo anunció en Múnich
Tuvimos una reunión y hablamos sobre
este tema veremos que hay en ese plan y
Sacaremos conclusiones a partir de ahí
pero debe haber ciertas líneas rojas
y creo que la línea roja común que
comparten China y Ucrania es el respeto
absoluto e incondicional por la
integridad territorial de los países
y si cualquier país del mundo no me
refiero específicamente a China si
cualquier país del mundo envía armas a
Rusia significa que está ayudando a
Rusia a violar la integridad territorial
indica que china lo está haciendo
dice cualquiera en este punto estoy
diciendo que si cualquier país del mundo
hace eso significa que ese país está
actuando en contra de los principios de
la integridad territorial
y los está destruyendo con sus propios
suministros
porque hay un detalle importante Ucrania
está ejerciendo el derecho a la legítima
defensa protegido por la carta de las
Naciones Unidas entonces enviar almas al
país que se está defendiendo es legítimo
significa que se está ayudando a que ese
país se defienda pero enviarle armas a
un agresor significa volverse un
responsable y un cómplice en el delito
de agresión usted mencionó el envío de
armas el presidente brasileño Lula da
Silva dijo que no enviaría armas a
Ucrania que no lo quiere hacer
ustedes y los aliados occidentales
tienen un problema que es convencer a
los países en Latinoamérica África y
Asia de que deberían apoyarlos
lo hemos visto en las Naciones Unidas
creo que usted irá allá para una nueva
votación
Por qué no se los puede convencer más
es una buena pregunta pero creo que la
respuesta correcta sería que hay una
gran cantidad de maneras en la que los
países se pueden expresar respecto a la
agresión rusa contra Ucrania
y si no pueden enviar armas pueden
apoyarnos políticamente expresando
solidaridad en las Naciones Unidas por
ejemplo
pueden abstenerse de apoyar a Rusia en
sus intentos por eludir las sanciones
Pueden hacer muchas cosas mientras no
estén ayudando a Rusia siempre pueden
encontrar maneras de ayudar a Ucrania
Pero por qué hay tantos países haciendo
esto Porque algunos están engañados por
la imagen de Rusia
unos han tenido históricamente buenas
relaciones con Rusia y
tratan de seguir siendo amigos tanto de
Rusia como de Ucrania
algo muy difícil de hacer bajo estas
circunstancias
respetamos todas las opiniones que hay
en el mundo porque son naciones
soberanas pero nuestro punto es muy
claro nos estamos defendiendo y es
legítimo apoyarnos Rusia está atacando
es ilegítimo apoyarlo de una manera u
otra
espero obtener más votos a favor de
Ucrania en las Naciones Unidas
donde debe haber una votación de la
asamblea general esta semana
Estamos trabajando en eso
definitivamente reunir votos en la
asamblea general de las Naciones Unidas
es el ejercicio clásico de la diplomacia
ahora Estamos particularmente
concentrados en trabajar con los países
del sur global a los que respetamos
y que quieran expresar su solidaridad
con Ucrania porque nos acercamos al
aniversario de la invasión a gran escala
también El noveno aniversario del
comienzo de la agresión rusa contra
Ucrania
en febrero de 2014 cuando se apoderaron
de crimea
Rusia ha violado literalmente cada Norma
del derecho internacional a partir de
ese momento y creo que es una decisión
totalmente natural defender la ley
internacional al apoyar a Ucrania
dimitro culeva Muchas gracias por estar
en la entrevista de France 24 y gracias
a ustedes por sintonizarla
[Música]